magical a good way to put it as Steve
cerr just said 132 to 126 Golden State
takes it in overtime uh I I've kind of
run out of adjectives to describe what
we see on a nightly basis from that guy
I think
timely like he understands the time the
score and the situation
so he's always going to be in the big
moments he understands like okay this is
an opportunity with down three for me to
kind of get us back in the game get the
crowd going I can make the play the pass
or the shot so he's just timely you know
of course he's a great scorer and great
shooter but some guys are not great
Shooters in the in in timely moments
they're just great Shooters you know we
could there's a lot of guys that have
done that but have they ever been timely
and consistently in the moment I would
say
no I'm wondering not saying I'm just
wondering because he's been consistently
the best shooter his whole career I'm
wondering is it time to start putting
him as the best player of all time best
player over you put him over you in in
the commentation I'm asking you yes you
put him over you you yourself Steph
Curry over you yeah that this is why
he's my favorite player cuz I'm not
saying favorite he might be my favorite
too but I'm just asking you think he
better than you play I played 20 years
watch 20 years before that I've never
seen a guy like him and he's doing it
consistently and he has championship
you
putting no I no I'm not putting them
anywhere I'm saying okay you know for
all the CH chatter is it time to just
put them in the conversation I think I
think he's a I'm asking the fans is it
time to you know start putting him in
the conversation as one of the best
players ever I'm GNA put it as a fan I
think in terms of position you could say
is he one of the best in his position
that ever play but I think the one thing
that separates
yourself
Jordan
LeBron is the ability to affect the game
in so many other areas well okay because
one part of one part one part of I'm not
saying one part of basketball it's for
Stu no we we have he's also had he's got
great teams and I'm not saying we're not
taking it away from his greatness to say
he's is it time to put him in the
conversation I'm just asking a question
yes or no if you're having the
conversation his name would come up no
no if I'm having a conversation as the
best player ever no yeah not as the best
player ever he can do it all except he's
he's he's the best position be best in
his position hey man he can do it all
listen his his title is solidified he's
the best shooter ever by far but I'm
saying because of what he's done and how
long he's done it do we put him in that
conversation me because you look at
Jordan 6 Kobe 5 he right there LeBron 4
I'm a barber shop talker like because I
can't I'm I'mma Be you're I'm I'mma put
myself in a barber shop that you're
talking about he is one of the best at
his position ever without question so
doesn't that put him in the conversation
you're saying okay so you wouldn't say
well let's let's put in let's put let's
put the best shooter of all time in the
conversation no no he's not the best
shooter of all time he might be one of
the best point guards of not just the
best shooter he's not just the best
shooter I know but but you might say
that if you're going to say here's our
pool of best player ever ever No that
pool is that pool wait wa what that pool
ain't deep that pool's not there not
deep water in there so you wouldn't
include the best there only there's only
like three he wouldn't include the best
shooter of all time in that conversation
I wouldn't bet include the best
rebounder of all time in that
conversation I wouldn't put a
statistical category in that pool that
pool is very thin who's in it Michael
Jordan got it LeBron James yes Kareem
Abdul Jabar yes and then we start
reaching no you don't
reach Mr Bean who Mr Kobe Bean is not in
that conversation he's he's right he's
next then we start reaching no yeah we
start reaching out there hope you being
and I'm I'm saying
I I think I put Steph Curry in that I'm
just saying to me those are that's the
pool of me Kareem LeBron Michael because
they dominate in so many areas they
could have an off shooting night and
affect everything that goes in the game
he had an offshoot night in the first
half you saw second half defensively
rebounding block shots come on you just
left me leadership
Ste he's a great now you say now he's
is's either one of top two three point
guards ever without question without
question but that doesn't qualify you
for the conversation of of all not best
player ever we've got that PO ain't a
lot of water in that pool hey golden R
water cooler
talk two something something something
and what did Kenny do his beard trying
to get
that it's a and a half it's called J I'm
trying to get it right that's his
sty